- Whoa!
- [Teacher] What do you see now?
- A penguin!
I can see a boat!
- [Mr. Berry] Surprise and Delight
is the heartbeat of our school.
It is that element of fun,
and excitement and engagement.
It's taking anything that
you normally would do,
and then trying to crank it up
to something that's awesome.
It is embedded in every
aspect of our culture.
Even the space itself.
We have holograms.
We have vending machines
that are stocked with student product.
We have the hallway made of lava tiles.
- Surprise and Delights also
happen within the classroom.
Oftentimes we use technology.
One of those Surprise and Delights
that students love a lot,
is the virtual field trip.
- [Teacher] Scientist. That's right.
What do you think the
scientist is studying?
- The penguin?
- [Teacher] The penguins, maybe?
He could be studying
penguins, you're right.
- You can change the place or the space,
it can be just a treat,
the activity itself.
- Okay, so guys, you all remember
that yesterday in class, we
read "Doughnuts Don't Lie"
and the author Angela Wilkinson
is a former graduate of
Eminence High School.
- Hello guys!
- [Students] Hi!
- Today we had the
opportunity to ask the author
of the book "Doughnuts
Don't Lie" questions.
- After publishing it, I did wonder.
Will people like this book?
- [Daynisha] Then Ms. Montgomery,
she gave us doughnuts.
- [Ms. Montgomery] I'll go ahead
and start this one down this way.
- They're so good!
(laughter)
- [Ms. Montgomery] The
Surprise and Delight
completely changes the school culture.
It makes it fun and exciting,
a great place to be.
- We want kids to want to be here.
We want them to be thinking differently,
and to make them creative,
and so Surprise and Delight,
it triggers new ideas for everybody.
- Another clue!
- Clue.
- A ha!